when Dana White first got involved in
the UFC back in 2001 he said he never
imagined that the sport would allow
female fights that all changed in 2013
when Dana White met Ronda Rousey who
went on to become one of the most famous
female Combat Sports athletes in the
world
so when you got into this 22 years ago
did you imagine there would be a
category for female Fighters
yeah no what you have to understand is
at that time
I was trying to get people to accept men
fighting in a cage which people thought
was horrible I saw a fight up in
Northern California
with two women
that was a horrible mismatch
and I was like oh my God
nobody's ready for this then I met Ronda
Rousey and it was ugly that was ugly I
mean you know you see a woman on her
back
taking elbows to the face yeah that she
can't defend and that she's not she
shouldn't even have been in this fight
it's rough to see you know uh you know
again I grew up and it comes off
chauvinistic sometime you know because I
know we live in a day and age where you
know women want to be equal and believe
me when I tell you women have proved
here that they are equal one of the
greatest fights that you will ever see
in your life is wayli Zhang versus
Joanna check and I don't mean female
fights one of the greatest fights you'll
ever see is that fight so they have
absolutely proven themselves and people
love the women's fights and they're so
Technical and they're so good it's just
I didn't see it coming and I didn't see
it happening that fast and women getting
even women who were boxing back in the
day it was like a novelty they had no
defense so they'd stand in front of each
other and just you know flail away and
you know people would go crazy but
nobody was like wow that woman is super
talented she's you know
you know her her style of fighting or
this or that
here
these women are unbelievable they're uh
very technical and very good and you
know from the numbers that the audience
responds no the audience doesn't respond
the audience loves it when I put a real
good woman's fight on the card a lot of
people show up for that fight they're
there that when you ask them you know
what's one of the highlights of tonight
why are you here I want to see wayli
Zhang and you want to own Jay check I
want to see you know Amanda Nunes versus
Giuliana Pena I want to see Ronda Rousey
these women become have become big stars
yeah famous yeah
it's awesome thank you and what's
different than uh from us than any other
these women are as equal as the men they
they fight the same amount of rounds in
non-title fights they fight the same
amount of rounds in championship fights
they get paid exactly the same as the
men do you know they don't hit from a
shorter T they don't have you know all
these other little handicaps they have
for women when they play in other sports
it's absolutely equal here for women and
men the meritocracy at work
and it's not a ring that I or Tucker I
think ever want to be in subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight